this is our best chance to begin
rebuilding our military and make
progress on issues directly affecting
the American people it's a good deal for
the American people and it's a strong
signal that we can break the gridlock
that has overwhelmed this body and work
together for the good of the country
Senate leaders Mitch McConnell and Chuck
Schumer busy today pushing that budget
deal that they negotiated to avoid
another government shutdown let's bring
in our panel Jonah Goldberg of National
Review Mara liason from National Public
Radio and Brian Kilmeade co-host of Fox
and Friends and author of the bestseller
Andrew Jackson and the miracle of New
Orleans
the battle that shaped America's destiny
will Mara the bill is stuck for the
budget deal is stuck at least for the
moment and for several hours on a
procedural issue in the Senate but even
if it passes there there's a real
question what happens in the house when
you've got opposition both from budget
deficit hawks and among Republicans and
people on Democrats who want to see the
dreamers included and what are the
chances tomorrow morning we're gonna
have another government shutdown well I
think there is a chance we could have
one I mean first of all you got to get
over the procedural hurdle of Rand Paul
which i think is doable you just gotta
wait a certain number of hours but then
in the house what's interesting is that
Paul Ryan wants a majority of the
majority in other words about 118 220
Republicans to vote for this I don't
know if he's gonna get that the fewer
Republicans he gets the more he needs
from Democrats and Democrats aren't in a
mood to help him out they wanted a
guarantee Nancy Pelosi stood on the
floor for eight hours so she could get a
guarantee from him that he would bring
up some kind of daca legislation on the
floor she hasn't really gotten what she
wanted he said yes I want to solve the
problem but I'm only gonna bring up
something that the president will sign
and so although the Democratic leaders
in the house aren't pushing all of their
members to vote no some of the leaders
like Pelosi Joe Crowley are saying they
are gonna vote against it was part of
the negotiation she said there's a lot
of good stuff in here for Democrats
she's not whipping it to get together
her members to vote no but she
personally isn't if they do pass this
one of the things we need to point out
is if this is
to blow up the deficit and let's take a
look at these numbers because they're
fascinating this is what the budget deal
would include a hundred and sixty five
billion dollars worn defense spending
over the next two years another hundred
sixty billion dollars separate from that
for the military and State Department
131 billion more for domestic spending
ninety billion in disaster relief 20
billion for infrastructure and six
billion for the opioid crisis take that
altogether that's more than five hundred
billion dollars over two years and added
military and domestic spending and then
add the tax bill which is gonna cost one
and a half trillion dollars over the
next decade by way of comparison the
total Obama stimulus plan spending and
tax cuts eight hundred and thirty five
billion dollars as you might imagine
deficit hawks are furious if we
Republicans support precisely the kind
of reckless spending that we've for so
long criticized it will mean an end of
genuine fiscal conservatism in
Washington Brian Kilmeade
whatever happened to the GOP is the
party of fiscal discipline well I mean
people out there watching you have to
say yeah we could be fiscal discipline
and Republicans can say yeah this is
what we are and Democrats say this will
we are and guess what we have nothing
gets done four six seven years nothing
significant gets done now you have a
situation where leadership says we have
to go fund the government and we want to
get a two-year deal and they watch
Secretary of Defense matters come out
and say the thing that's hurting our
defense and the Pentagon worse than any
other enemy is what's happening in
Congress not fully funding us we can't
exist like this so what Paul Ryan and
Mitch McConnell says is this would they
want domestic spending we want defense
spending so we we give this money to
domestic spending and if you look out of
it a lot of it goes to what the Trump
agenda is to infrastructure it goes to
it goes to opioids it goes to cancer
research so you get the Trump agenda
moving forward on one on one hand then
you fully fund the Defense Department
for two full years and then what you do
is you go back and do entitlements after
that because it's the automatic
withdrawals from our bank account which
is hurting us not the discretionary
spending well I want to get to the
entitlement as part of that with you
Jonah but I also
want to talk about the split among
Democrats because you've got Chuck
Schumer the leader of the Democrats in
the Senate saying this is a great deal
and then you have Nancy Pelosi who was
was pointed out helped negotiate it but
now she's against it take a look I have
a nun unease with it and hope that the
speaker will man up and decide that we
in the house can also have what's a
Mitch McConnell guaranteed in the Senate
a vote I vote on the floor Jonah how
serious is this divide among Democrats
given the fact that this bill can't pass
teeth of the Senate or the house without
a lot of Democratic votes particularly
in the house yeah I mean I think Mars
right it can pass in the Senate it'll
just take longer on the house side you
have the problem I think viral New York
said this last night here that what
Nancy Pelosi did was basically an
exercise in virtue signaling the base of
the party is very deeply committed to
getting something on daca they wanted to
hold Rhines feet to the far she can't
force anything so she wanted to at least
be on record with some very big symbolic
show on the entitlement thing I just got
a disagree with Brian about this one of
the reasons why this is such a great
deal for Democrats is that this would
make any possibility of Republicans
doing anything through reconciliation
impossible now reconciliation is the
process by which Republicans in the
Senate would only 50 votes to get
something done but they need to pass a
budget to do that that's right there is
no way getting rid of reconciliation
that the Republicans are gonna be able
to do entitlement reform and get enough
Democrats to vote for it this basically
guarantees that the Republicans going
into 2018 will have no other big
legislative items on their agenda
they're not gonna be able to do any of
the fixes to Obamacare that they wanted
to do this is one of the reasons why why
Chuck Schumer really likes this deal
except for the daca part there is
nothing in this deal that Democrats
shouldn't love and there's and while
there's an individual spending I could
defend it particularly on the military
this basically amounts to basically a
death knell for the Tea Party messaging
of the Republican Party Brian you've got
45 seconds to tell Jonah why he's wrong
there are a lot as you know is the
famous a lot of the Democratic senators
in these red states so after they get
this done there's going to be a lot of
who lo who have to turn around to their
constituents and say yeah
be fiscal responsibility too so how many
do you need to get you need to get about
eight so if they get the budget that
they want and there's a sense in March
six they'll get some type of dock a deal
that they could get why not do why do
you think Jonah can we be a little bit
optimistic that people gonna say you
know welfare is a mess Social Security
needs to be addressed and we can start
pulling some of this in with Medicare
and you're about to smoke out there you
because I've been paying attention to
Congress for the last 15 years
president Trump has promised not to cut
Medicare Medicaid or social security
entitlement reform is not going to
happen I don't think in an election year
you're gonna have Republicans vote to
cut these in Tyler he also say he's
gonna build a solid wall now he says I'm
gonna have search in certain areas where
I don't need that I'm gonna use
technology you could pull back from that
and I look how he's going back in his
work all right
at least you're optimistic and we
appreciate that next top even if you
really know I always appreciate